[Music]
look at this man running he is training
to run a marathon he's covering a
distance of 3 meters every second so the
distance he covers each second is
constant at 3 meters and he maintains
the pace for a certain period of time
this is what we describe as uniform
motion so in case of uniform motion if
we know the constant distance covered
for each time period along with the
total time duration of motion we can
calculate the total distance covered
what do I mean by this if I said this
man ran at a uniform speed of 3 meters
per second for a minute can you tell me
how much sense he covered a minute is 60
seconds each second runner covered three
meters so 60 times 3 is 180
don't forget the unit's the answer would
be 180 meters similarly we can calculate
how much distance he will cover in 10
minutes 20 minutes or even an hour
that's because he is maintaining a
constant speed uniform motion distance
traveled by an object in unit time is
called speed it's distance per unit time
so what will be the unit can you guess
the SI unit of speed is meters per
second quite often you will also see
speed denoted in centimeters per second
miles per hour or kilometers per hour
but the standard unit roommate's meters
per second we observe this gentleman
here running at a constant speed of 3
meters per second he is definitely a
thorough professional but in our
day-to-day lives it is very rare to see
uniform motion whether it is walking or
running riding a bicycle of being in a
car we walk briskly for a while and then
get tired and our pace slows down most
of the times they're not even in control
of the speed there are external factors
like traffic traffic lights busy clouded
area
and like the bicycle ride is faster
times and slow at other times depending
on which area of the school you are in
same goes for driving a car such cases
are examples of non-uniform motion the
speed of the object is not constant hang
on can be calculate speed for
non-uniform motion as the motion is not
uniform it will have different speeds at
different points in time when it comes
to non-uniform motion we refer to the
rate of motion in terms of average speed
yes that's right
average speed so how can we derive
average speed this boy leaves point 8 to
reach point B which is 60 meters away
from a and he has been walking at varied
rates of motion basically non uniform
motion he takes 60 seconds to reach
point B so he has covered 60 meters in
60 seconds what is his speed can you
tell you just probably guessed we look
at the total distance covered and
divided by the time taken to arrive upon
the speed so this boy has covered 60
meters in 60 seconds so 60 divided by 60
equals one meter per second that's his
average speed over this distance it is
as simple as that but you have to be
careful with the units used what you
have to get into the habit right away
and stick to standard units if you
understand it well right now it will
help avoid silly mistakes in the future
if I had said this boy has covered 60
meters in one minute you should not make
the mistake of writing 60 divided by one
equals 60 and say he is traveling at a
speed of 60 meters per second that's as
fast as a bike the best way normally
would be to convert to standard units so
let's convert 120 meters in a minute
into meters per second
meters is already in standard form at
the standard form of speed is meters per
second we need to convert this minute
into seconds one minute equals 60
seconds
this would mean distance covered was 120
meters in 60 seconds so what was the
distance covered in one second
correct two meters per second so make
sure to stick to standard units for now
and always mention the unit's being used
average speed is a good way to know when
you will reach a certain destination in
traffic there will be times when you
will be driving fast and other times you
will be stuck hold on at every instance
you are moving up some speed it may be 0
meters per second when you're stuck or 2
meters per second or even 4 meters per
second do you know what the speed at
each instant is called it is called
instantaneous speed